hi I miss my own 29 I'm a penetration
tester whoa
I want to ask you what pisses you off I
gotta know what is a penetration tester
I'm a professional hacker and criminal
basically criminal do you not know how
cameras work this is not the dark web
this is real life the camera is on you
the government pays me since you're a
hacker you know you go deeper online
than any of us what is it online that
pisses you off the phrase life hack
because it disrespects what you do yeah
I mean cutting an apple and happens not
a hack it's a thing people have done
right right cutting an apple not a hack
it disrespects what I do which is
robbing a family of all their livelihood
online I know there have enough money
and going after the biggie when a person
is life how you're like off poser
you know I robbed I robbed Merrill Lynch
I did not oh yeah he did not rob Merrill
Lynch can you tell me what government
agency you work for no whoa mal is a
straight-up degenerate illegitimate
hacker working for the government
he got Jeff Sessions all over him I
guess we're do you think you could hack
into my stuff and take my money yes I
don't have that much clear cute I'm cute
it's my
[Music]